all right um
so your basics will work in combination
with each other
um
ones you're going to find
usually there's four
in my experience
at the beginner level that work well
together okay
one is that is the mount reversal
other one is
elbow knee
this one
this variant too
and then last
uh
you get him
off to the side
and come over okay
they will feed each
other however
that's a tactical system
you also have a strategic system
and that is
um
kazushi
always go for kazushi
it's very difficult for him
to launch an attack
while he has to choose between launching
the attack
and maintaining his balance and hence
his positioning or his dominance
um so
as he goes to strike
uh you would affect
his kazushi
as as he's doing that his balance it
would affect his balance okay
so for example he goes to strike
and here
and you got the other one
you'll see it there
as opposed to
trying for that one when he hasn't done
anything
i try for that one
and he'll be able to do different things
including that punch
on the next beat so
i go off get his balance and he comes
back and punches
so always pay attention he can't do both
at the same time so use kazushi to stop
a lot of his things
and then two when you learn the moves
without the strikes
you get to do them wherever you want
in space um
but
it's not so free for all
you have to pay attention to his power
lines
okay and that's his shoulder lines
so for example
um
let's say i'm going to do
uh this one
my head
is underneath this power line of his
shoulder
so when i go to pass his leg it's when
i'm going to get popped
instead
i have to
get off that power line in this case by
going deeper into him
than not paying attention to this power
line
so
generally you'll go in deeper
past it
or
to the outside of it okay it doesn't
really work to get up here because he
just moves with you and the power line
is on there you can do that as he
punches even boom you see
so it's usually he goes usually you're
in tight
or same thing you're outside
okay in tight or outside
is where you want to be
your last resort
should be
tying him up okay
so
let's say
i'm trying to get his balance
he comes back with the punch maybe
that's where i tied him up okay
um but you'll see oh that's mount
reversal
but if i do it in a way
that i'm not paying attention to those
first two things you're going to get
punched over here with the other hands
he punches me boom and you're going to
let go of that thing okay
so again maybe i he goes to punch pull
he comes back right go to the outside
and now i have
uh this that one that i wanted do you
see how that works okay
so just be cognizant
that as you try tie ups
[Music]
that you can't violate the other two
rules so i got no kazushi right now and
i'm on the power line on the shoulders
you're going to get knocked okay
all right
let's work that four-point dilemma
and
try to work these strategies
okay
uh watch your desk just go watch your
desperation your arms are out here okay
this is not ever good you don't
ever go past
your frame okay um
because he can he'll he can trap my arms
and create uh
his arm attacks he can isolate them so
you can travel arm get it outside and
create an angle of attack do you see oh
crap he's gonna get two three good
solid punches from that
so
uh as you're doing your moves you're
going to find out the jiu-jitsu
principle works best
is you wait for him to do something the
most i will do
is kazushi okay and so most of your
kazushi
is going to come from
the
bridge
okay so the most i'll do is
a bridge
to get him now he has to do something
you see so as he goes to do something
that's when i move my arms never really
over extend okay
and same thing it's like oh you're so
close but don't you can't extend your
arms so you move your body instead
is what you'll do
okay
um
if he goes ahead and punches first
then it's easy it's much easier okay
just remember he can't do both so if
he's not doing one i will do the other
that's how it kind of works okay
um
so
he goes and i'm just
in close and this was a knee bump to
deal with his balance okay
so he'll do something again
and i attack that kazushi again with
another nepa
he goes again
and you could already feel that this
knee was up
on the last move and so again
i'm out he's going to try something else
whoa
whatever you don't get don't over extend
to get it just play that play it oh play
it
if you want him to stop punching you
take his balance he'll stop punching you
don't try to stop him like this
he goes again
[Music]
his knee couldn't get down
this knee couldn't get down
so i'll do it i'll go as far as i can
he's going to want to come back though
and that's right go to the other spot
worst case scenario go ahead that's fine
boom i'll tie but i don't want to use my
muscles and i'm on that shoulder line so
i'm not really looking for that
but i'm making him have to do something
so he goes
as you're training
you can do a couple things i want you to
do one or two things okay
one is you you give him stuff to work
with okay
um
so in other words i'm not gonna sit here
and
and and try to try to crush him and he
can't move i want to give him stuff to
work with
okay
so i can
do my thing
are you going to do your thing
i do my thing
right
doing my thing
just giving him stuff to work
now you can see how he keeps staying on
that shoulder line you see
even as you do that one
you're going to get better at your
balance so you can see i'm not really
competing against him i'm not really
freaking out you see that
um
so
he's trying to do kazushi on me but
it there is a balance and there's an
athleticism to whether kazushi works or
not okay
so how well i am
at a dynamic equilibrium
that's how much more difficult it is for
him to gain kazushi and i make him
better as he makes me better okay
um without having to freak out you see
i'm
i'm not really doing anything but i'm
not going into victimland
when he does kazushi do you understand
because
on his side which i already explained
he's supposed to use
partial kazushi to continue another
kazushi do you see not start all over he
keeps starting all over okay um if
you're with someone who's better than
that
you can up your uh
your punching game where you start to
train your punches you're not
just uh giving him
something to work with
he's giving you something to work with
okay as well i have to do my role but
once he gives me something to work with
i will work with that okay so i'm doing
my point here we go i do my punches
right
and oh there it is
and then boom
so i'm going to look for these striking
traps and then i'll reset the drill you
can go it doesn't buck because you're
still on the shoulder line
so see when he reaches and he pushes
there it is there every single time okay
so you punch and look how he dropped the
elbow do you see and well there's the
gift wrap now and now i have two
checks on him okay
so i might look for that
what i don't want you to do
is you go and you're like oh yeah
th this is more sparring not training
okay
i want you if you lose your balance once
you come back and give them things to
work on again oh
boom
back in
boom because when i came here he should
have done something when i go back to
this attack but he keeps waiting
and you cannot wait for strikes the
movement go you just buck me here pay
attention that i'm going to come back up
and start looking to work with this
energy
do you understand
so you come here
and i buck you all that way
and you're going to come back and that's
the energy that i'm going to use do you
understand do you see how that did
you come here
you back and you go didn't work
and then you're going here
that's not going to work either
you get the partial
boom he comes back
boom and i'm looking for this thing this
knee is light i'm out
okay all right
let's go okay so your question was
the guy
is really squeezing okay so he's he's
using his uh
muscles
to
uh hold hold me in place do you see that
okay
so
you feel his power right
but not for example squeeze your legs
i don't really feel it when do i feel it
what do i try to open your legs
do you unders do you get it so when i'm
trying to push your legs that's when i
feel that okay
so my question to you was
um
let's i'll ask it plainly now
if you feel his legs squeezing you
should you be pushing his legs away from
you
no that's not jiu-jitsu now do you see
that okay
so
look for the move where this
fits okay
what go ahead and squeeze your legs
and you tell me all the places where you
feel my body pressing on your body
right now
where
uh you're not pressing no you are
pushing on my body right now there's an
integrity to my friend
where do you feel it on your body
on this inside where else
on my heels right here
do you see
what move of those four is helped by
this foot being right there
just finished
okay so
if you look at when you are squeezing in
well your base has a narrowing energy
do you understand okay and that's why i
do this
because if i don't do that and i go for
the amount reversal you'll use that
widening base dc to stop the kazushi
but you're doing it now right now
do you see
so
instead of trying to push this open
do the move for when the legs are closed
so you're trying all your punches right
and i'm going to attack
that ankle that you were attacking me
with do you see and now
what happened over here
it's light and i'm out
okay
so you can see
you need to figure out my intention
get
on
okay so what he's doing is
he is trying not to
be bucked off
well in that effort
is another opening that's jiu jitsu okay
so
this is what i just did
do you see and so i'll go for this one
right and what's he going to do he's
going to do something but i'll still
take the kazushi do you see
because that kazushi
is going to be
easier
than this one
as he goes to pull up
center of gravity is higher now and this
leg over here is light so let's say
he really squeezes down again
okay
well that's going to make the foot light
so the foot is light
and you're out same thing is he gonna
regain out now
no he's not
it's just one
push
shrimp
you're
out so look for
[Music]
how he creates the opening okay so for
example
this one where you were coming under
it's going to be harder
for you to try to come under
than it is
to wait for him
to come up
do you understand so if he wants to stay
down there and i'm going to try to get
him no no no but
if i go
boom
here
and i buck him forward
right and he smells high guard
i'm out you see he smells that go back
and i go
boom and he smells it
and i'm already there
got it okay so all these moves are
going to be easier
if you do the one
that works with what he's doing then if
you try to make a move happen
okay that's what jiu jitsu is he gives
me the opening he gives me the energy
for this
resolution
okay
try to stop making things happen
let the things happen okay
now if you going from move to move
like he was
you're never going to be able to do this
okay so in other words he did
the bridge
it didn't work
and he stopped and he wanted to start
over here it's never going to happen
because
i get to reset everything all at once
okay and what did i have him do
is look for the energy here this energy
to work with do you see
so if he wants to take me
to one side it's going to be harder if
i'm sitting here
and he tries to take me
this way it's going to be hard but if
i'm moving that way then it's going to
be easy
for him you see so he's doing the move
in relation to
the energy that i'm giving him that's
you you are
at the beginning your technique is going
to be responsive
okay and it's definitely a skill set you
want
one once you understand
a communion
it's not responsive
it's not reactionary and it's not agency
either but at the beginning
to do moose to try to try for moves is
not to do the art okay
try to do